[MUSIC PLAYING]
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir--
Live Webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Melody
Meckfessel, and today we're
going to be talking
about the secrets
of top-performing DevOps teams.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
Thank you so much
for being here, Jez.
I'm so excited to
spend this time today
learning about your research
in high-performing DevOps teams
and to share some examples
from Google's experience.
JEZ HUMBLE: Thanks very
much for having me.
It's a pleasure and
an honor to be here.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Great.
So let's dive right in.
We're going to talk a
little bit about defining
DevOps to orient us all
around what's included in it.
We're going to dig into some
of the fascinating research
from DORA around
DevOps performance.
We're also going to
talk about some findings
and how we balance speed with
stability in terms of software
development, dig into how we
can all improve as a community--
both individuals,
teams in a community--
and then finish up talking
a little bit about the role
that open source is
playing in DevOps.
JEZ HUMBLE: So what is DevOps?
There's no agreed
definition of DevOps.
I'm sure you have a
different one from me.
Somehow mine hasn't
made it onto the slide.
So I like to think
of DevOps in terms
of the goals we're
trying to achieve
and the people who are trying
to achieve those goals.
So I like to talk about a
community of practice dedicated
to building, evolving,
and operating
rapidly changing, secure,
resilient systems at scale.
So that's what
we're trying to do.
It's hard.
We haven't worked it out yet.
We're all improving
all the time.
There's three key areas that
I think we need to think about
and that our research
covers and that we're
going to talk about today.
Number one is
organizational culture--
we'll be spending a
lot of time talking
about that- technical
practices; and then,
finally, management
practices, which are also
important if you're going to
achieve the kind of things we
talk about.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: So as
developers and operators,
we're really focused on
how do we take that idea
and get it out to
the user community
so that they can
get value out of it.
And I think it's
interesting to think
about where we are in
terms of how DevOps
is enabling us to do that.
So we have the idea of taking
that idea and understanding
what the requirements
are of the business,
like writing down
what features do
we think we need to actually
go fingers on the keyboard,
develop code around.
And there used to be this
wall of throwing requirements
back and forth between the
business and development.
Well, Agile really
helped us solve that wall
and break it down.
But as we both know,
there's another wall
that has existed between
development and operations.
So once the code
is done, it needs
to be operated
out in production.
And there's a wall that
exists of sort of throwing
the release over, so to speak.
DevOps is helping us
break down that wall
and help increase the
velocity and the practices
around moving from
development-- writing,
building, and testing
code-- into operating
at scale from production
with the intent
that as we increase
that cycle time
and improve the reliability,
we're delivering better quality
results out to the market
and out to the users.
So the research--
again, fascinating
to see the impact of DevOps
on overall performance.
So software delivery
performance--
there's some information
that comes out
around the difference
between high performers
and elite performers.
And we see from your research
that elite performers
are 1.53 times more likely to
exceed their business outcomes.
And those outcomes are
measured by productivity.
They're measured
by profitability,
by market share-- real
concrete, positive measures
in terms of getting the
software out to the end
users and the market.
It's fascinating
to see that impact.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah, absolutely.
And I think that has been
one of the big outcomes from
our research for
the last few years--
seeing that has a
business impact--
also just having a way to
measure DevOps' performance.
So Google-- obviously,
very metrics focused.
We found a valid
and reliable way
to measure our software
delivery performance, which
helps us also understand how
to change performance as well.
We can do statistical
research on the factors
that improve performance.
And again, we'll talk
about that today.
So how do we
measure performance?
Two kinds of measures--
measures of throughput--
how fast we're going--
so deploy frequency, how
frequently we deploy--
and then lead time for changes--
how fast can we go from version
control-- coding
version control--
to production.
Then to stability
measures-- so time
to restore service if there's
an incident or an outage
or service degradation-- how
quickly can we restore service.
And then change
fail rate is kind
of a measure of the quality
of our release process.
When you push out a change,
what percentage of the time
do we need to roll forward
or roll back and remediate.
And if there's kind of one
thing to take away from this,
it's high performance
and not trading off
speed and stability.
We kind of have this
idea that going fast-- it
means breaking things.
That's not the case.
Consistently over five years,
we find that high performers are
better at throughput
and stability,
and low performers are worse
at throughput and stability.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
And it's interesting
when you think about it.
You have to come back
and fix the problem.
[LAUGHS] So you want to
decrease the amount of time
for that meantime to resolve.
JEZ HUMBLE: Right.
Exactly.
I mean, failure's inevitable.
We're operating complex systems.
You've got to take that
into consideration.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Absolutely.
JEZ HUMBLE: So here's
what we found this year.
Every year we do
cluster analysis
and we find groups
within our data
that behave in similar ways.
This year, we
found four groups--
a low-performing
group that's releasing
pretty infrequently, between
once a week and once a month.
Their lead time for changes
is measured in months.
It takes them a long time
to restore service as well.
And their change fail rate
is between 46% and 60%.
So that's at the bottom end.
Again-- doing badly at
all of those measures.
And then up at the top end, we
have these elite performers,
that 7% of our total.
They're deploying on demand.
So they have multiple
deployments per day.
It takes them less than an hour
to get changes from version
control to production.
If they need to remediate
because there's a problem,
they can do that in
less than an hour.
And we think that's
because they're
able to use the normal process
for remediation as well.
There's no special
emergency process,
where you skip a
bunch of the testing.
You can just use
your regular process.
And their change fail
rates are really low.
They have a really high
quality release process.
This year, we extended
our measure of performance
to also include availability.
So availability-- obviously, new
users can access your service.
And also, you can make
promises about the availability
of your systems--
so say that your users and your
customers can rely on them.
Again, we find that people
are not making trade-offs.
They're not going faster, and
availability's going down.
In fact, quite the opposite.
Elite performers, in terms of
software delivery performance,
are 3.55 times more likely
to have strong availability
practices.
So these things all go together.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: So
let's talk a little bit
about that balancing
of speed with stability
because we know that
users' expectations
around availability
are increasing.
So as an end user, if I go to
use a particular app or system,
I expect it to be up.
I expect it to be available.
So I just wanted to start
by grounding in the fact
that us as a DevOps community
and as software teams make
decisions around
availability-- and I
think we need to remember that
perfection is unrealistic.
As far as I know--
keep me honest here--
no human has ever created a
perfectly reliable system.
And if we look out to nature,
we see the same thing--
competitive pressures,
evolution of systems.
Perfect reliability is
not the best target.
So let's talk a
little bit about why.
And I think it comes back to
perfection can be wasteful.
So your users of your
application and your system
have many other dependencies.
This is the reality with
infrastructure and cloud
infrastructure.
And your users
experience reliability
as all of those
dependencies together,
of which your service is one.
So it's important to
come back to thinking
about the expectations
of your users
and the overall expectation
of those dependencies
and your understanding of them.
They may not notice.
I'm going to give an
example here in a second.
They may not notice
the difference
in adding two 9's to
your availability,
but they're probably
going to notice the cost.
So what is the goal around
setting these availability
and reliability targets?
It's really to make
our users happy.
They expect this
level of availability.
And we as DevOps teams have
to balance the features
that we're giving to the
users with their expectations
of reliability.
So we want to set those
reliability targets
to be in line with
the other dependencies
that the users have accepted
and to understand that.
Insufficient reliability--
it makes unhappy users.
Our goal is to make
our users happy.
But if we have
excessive reliability,
we're going to
waste opportunities
to launch features and to
release at high velocity
as Jez mentioned.
So think about the trade-off
that's being made there.
And there's a bunch of
factors that can go into this.
Users have different
expectations around service
levels that are set.
There's things that
we can consider around
expectations for paid
services versus free services.
What's happening with
competitors in this market?
What are they setting
their reliability targets?
And always to come back
to the cost side of this.
There's a human cost--
effort and time-- to hit
certain reliability targets
and availability targets.
So we need to consider
that in the decisions
that we make as DevOps teams.
And at Google, we found that
this objective metric, called
an error budget, helps balance
availability with velocity.
So you take 100% percent.
You set your
availability target.
And you have your
error budget so
that product management,
developers, and SRE are all
working off the same metric.
And there's flexibility
as we'll see.
If you have error
budget remaining,
maybe you are going to take
more risks on the release side,
having that understanding of
how your service is operating.
So this is an example.
You can see here-- and
I just want to call out
the difference-- if you have
an availability target of three
9's, you have around--
you can see per year, per
quarter, 30 days in this slide.
But you can see you have
about 2.16 hours of allowed
unavailability.
So that's downtime.
That's time that
your users are not
going to be able to
use your application.
If you wanted to target five
9's, which, for some systems,
that may be correct, you've
only got 1.30 minutes.
I mean, that's--
JEZ HUMBLE: --terrifying.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
It's terrifying.
So we really want to come back
to you can set this metric.
Make sure it's in line
with the dependencies.
with the user expectations.
And know what the
trade-offs are going
to be because that level
of service may be required,
but it comes at a cost.
So what are the benefits of
creating these error budgets?
We're going to talk about
culture in a little bit,
but creating common incentives
and a shared fate, or a shared
responsibility, around
uptime is so critical.
And we found at Google that
between developers and SREs,
this is the way that we balance
innovation and reliability.
And the other aspect of this
that I find really important
is that the developers
become self-policing.
So the operators-- you know
that wall between development
and operations that we talked
about-- just really break this
down, where everyone has a
common goal around uptime
and developers know
where those trade-offs
can be made-- maybe
where we can take more
risks around future velocity.
But everyone's on the same page.
Everyone's oriented
around that metric.
And I have examples within
my development team,
where we were all looking
at the error budget
and seeing where we
stand for the quarter
and making sure that we're
falling within our availability
targets.
Super important.
JEZ HUMBLE: OK.
So we talked a bit about
what's important to measure
and how you can think
about those measurements
and use them to drive
changes in behavior.
We're going to talk a bit
about how you actually
get better at this stuff.
What are the things
that you can do
if you're not doing so well
in terms of performance that
can shift you to the
left in this case?
And shifting left is
going to be a big theme.
So three things
we're going to talk
about and that we've measured
over the last five years--
technical practices,
culture, and management.
So obviously, a lot of the focus
of DevOps is on automation.
We're going to talk
about some of the tools
that you use at Google.
Automation is, obviously,
very important.
And in our data
this year, we find
that elite performers have
high levels of automation,
low levels of manual work.
This is interesting.
This is something you can
only measure through surveys.
You can't look at system
data and find out how much
manual work is being done.
You can only find
out by asking people.
We see the low performers are
doing much more manual work
when they're doing
configuration management,
deployments, testing,
change approval process
than our elite
performers are doing.
And that should be no surprise.
One of the things that
elite performers do
is find ways to automate
things that are repetitive.
They're algorithmic.
But these numbers are not 0.
And it's important to bear in
mind that there will always
be manual work.
There's always going to
be things that you're
going to have to do.
Continuous delivery--
there's this misconception
that some people have that it's
about automating everything,
that we're going to get rid
of testers, for example.
Absolutely not the case.
There's still manual
work to be done--
exploratory testing,
usability testing--
that's critically important.
The other thing to
point out about this
is that you can't just take
complex and painful processes
and automate them.
You have to simplify.
And so there's a
simplification piece
in terms of
architecture processes
that has to go hand in
hand with automation.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: You found
here that-- we talk about toil
a lot, and there's many
dimensions of toil.
But you can clearly see how
automation is coming into play,
from low performers
to elite performers,
to really make time
to address the toil
and to factor those improvements
back into the workflow.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah.
And actually, it's not
in the presentation,
but in the report, we
look at the amount of time
that people are
spending on new feature
development versus non-value-add
work, like fixing problems.
And we find that
elite performers--
50% of their time is spent on
value-add work versus toil.
So it's an interesting
reflection of something
that you observed at Google.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Right.
JEZ HUMBLE: So how
do you actually
improve your performance
from a technical perspective?
Well, over the five years
that we've been doing this,
we found a whole bunch
of different practices.
Obviously, there's the classic
continuous delivery practices,
good configuration management
and version control,
continuous integration,
automation around the test
and deploy process.
This year, we also looked
at continuous testing,
which is we're not just going
to automate some of our testing.
We're also going to build
testing work into the software
delivery lifecycle, have testers
working alongside developers,
testing process.
Monitoring and
observability-- turns out
those things are important.
Obviously, you spend a lot
of time thinking about that
and doing that at Google.
So that has a big
impact on your ability
to deliver with
speed and stability,
building database management
and security into the delivery
process--
again, shifting
left on that stuff.
And we'll talk about security
in just a little bit.
Those things together all impact
software delivery performance
positively, and availability.
Interestingly, they also
positively impact culture.
So we'll talk about
culture in a bit.
But how do you change culture?
Well, you change it by
changing how people work
and how they behave.
Technical practices
are a big part of that.
Also want to point out
these technical practices
reduce deployment pain, and
they also reduce team burnout.
So obviously, we
want to avoid teams
that are working crazy hours
and feeling a lot of stress.
That's bad for the humans, and
that results in bad outcomes.
These practices can
reduce burnout as well.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
It's so important.
So I wanted to share
an example that I
think demonstrates a lot of
the principles and findings
that you found.
So Google invests
significantly in code review.
You can see a stat here-- about
20,000 code reviews a day.
We do this as a way to invest in
education among the developers
and operators that are
writing code and trying
to get those features
out to our end users.
But it's a significant
investment in quality.
We want quality
code because we want
to find the issues before we're
further along in the deployment
pipeline.
And we want to
find it definitely
before it gets out
to the end users
as much as we possibly can.
So we've invested a lot in
automation around code reviews.
And the intention behind this is
to have that automation free up
the humans' time to focus on
the content and the quality
and the improvements that
can be made to the code.
So we've incorporated things.
We call them robo-reviews--
robot code reviews--
where we're looking for
checks and tests and analyzers
that can do things
like enforce the style
and formatting because we know
that increases readability,
and it makes it
easier for the humans
to interact with the code.
Compiler-based analyzers to
look for problematic patterns
in the code so that we
can prompt the developers
and operators to look at that
and take action based on it.
Custom analyzers-- we've
created an internal community,
an ecosystem, around
custom analyzers
that different engineering
teams can adopt.
And then if those are valuable,
other teams can adopt them.
So you're creating a community
around these types of analysis.
And then, finally, building
all of this-- build and test--
into the CI system
so that the code--
we're running the
test, and we're
catching issues in the code.
And we're surfacing
those in the code reviews
as fast as we possibly
can to catch it
before it incurs the cost in
the rest of the development
workflow.
JEZ HUMBLE: And I
find it, I mean,
really fascinating
that you invested
so much effort into
making the code review
process smooth and easy.
One of the things
we talk about is
working in small
batches, developers
being able to make small
changes and push them in.
That is critical-- to have
a code review process that
is simple and smooth so that
you can do that very frequently.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah,
I think there's definitely
some interesting points there
around taking risk and knowing
that the automation is there and
then doing those small batches
to be able to
release as frequently
as the teams possibly can.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
So beyond code review, we
want to build automation
into the entire workflow.
And it's great because
developers and operators just
continue to raise the bar
on the level of automation.
Definitely shows up in
the elite performers
and how they're
spending their time.
So if we start, and we
just go around the circle,
we have Cloud
Source Repositories
to help with version
control, to present search,
and different levels of
insight into the code-- so
fingers on the
keyboard writing code.
Then we go with 2, 3, and 4
into the build, test, and deploy
pipeline.
So Cloud Build-- we'll talk
about security in a second--
but the ability to build
and test your application.
And then, using
Container Registry,
be able to then take it into
Spinnaker, an open source
deployment system, to
release your code--
high-quality code-- to
the underlying platform
whether that's Compute Engine,
Kubernetes Engine, or App
Engine.
But we can't stop there.
So we have systems
like Stackdriver
that are monitoring,
alerting, and logging
to look for if we
deployed something,
and there's an increased
rate of errors,
we're going to make
sure we take a look.
The operators can take a
look at that and take action.
And we actually have ways
to then bring that back
to code that exists in the repo.
And then we go around
again to fix the issue.
So I think this cycle of
continuous improvement
with insights and then
building that automation
into the workflow really
makes the developers
and operators feel like these
systems have their back.
And then they're going to
focus on the high value
content-related tasks that
they need to do with the code
and with the service.
JEZ HUMBLE: And I
love the fact you've
got all of these
feedback loops going back
to developers from all the
different parts of the delivery
pipeline here.
That's really great.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Great.
JEZ HUMBLE: So security--
finally, we made it.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: We all
have to care about it.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah.
I mean, this is
something I often
say-- that you can't build
stuff that doesn't have security
and performance and have
the magic DevOps pixies come
after dev complete and
wave their magic wand
and fix the security and
performance and availability.
You have to build it in.
So we find in our research--
building security into the
software delivery process,
shifting left, improves not just
software delivery performance,
but also the quality
of your security.
So it improves both outcomes.
When we gather the
data this year,
we find that elite performers
are building security in.
And they can do security reviews
and remediate any problems
they find in the space of days
whereas low performers are
taking weeks-- not just to
conduct security reviews,
but also to fix the
problems that they
find when they're doing them.
So that's a real problem and a
real constraint for many people
in their delivery process.
So what do we want to do?
We want to build security--
and by running security tests
as part of the
deployment pipeline,
as you've talked about, and
I think you're going to talk
about a bit more--
and making it easy
for developers
to consume libraries that
are known to be good.
Obviously, if there's a CVE
discovered in a library,
you want to be able to get
a fixed version of that
and get that out into
production as quickly
as you possibly can--
another instance where
time to restore services
is really important.
Lead times are really important.
Make sure that your
toolchains and your processes
help developers build
security in as well.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
The timeliness of security
reviews, the ability
for the developers to react.
And then where we go next is
building that automation in
to help them from the beginning.
So just some examples.
Again, Jez talked
about shifting left.
We're writing code, but
then we need to build it.
And as part of that
build, the code
may be changed by
multiple people
on the team, multiple
dependencies.
So we've built vulnerability
scanning into Cloud Build
to detect those issues
so that we know ahead
of time, before we get
further down in the deployment
pipeline, where
there's a problem.
We're also building in policy
creation and enforcement
to give the power and control
to the developers and operators,
and to software teams,
to be able to enforce
certain policies, like
binary authorization.
So if you look at just
these two pieces--
and I think these are
really the beginning-- we're
getting to the point where
we have something that's
trusted that we can then deploy
and really understand that this
is a high-quality release that's
going out because what we want
to know is if there's
something that's
untrusted, if there is a
security vulnerability,
and empower the DevOps teams
to act on that before they
get further in the pipeline.
So we're tightening that
loop around security
to address those issues
long before it makes it
to the end users.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah.
And I know that--
I mean, security is so critical.
For Google, you have
systems like email
that state actors are
trying to interfere with.
So this is a great example
of how, actually, these
practices really help
with improving security.
So management practices.
So management is important
as well, obviously.
Over the years, we've found
that lean approaches to product
management are really critical
at improving performance
and culture and those
organizational outcomes we
talked about--
profitability, market share,
quality, customer satisfaction.
What we find is working
in small batches;
developing small-feature
increments, prototypes;
pushing those out to
production; getting feedback
from real users; and
then iterating rapidly
to build things that deliver
the outcomes you want
for your users and
your organization,
enabling teams to experiment.
We're not throwing
requirements over the wall
to order-taking
development teams.
Development teams actually have
input into what gets built.
I mean, you have these
highly trained, experienced
professionals building software.
They have ideas and
opinions, and it's crazy
not to leverage that.
So we find that those practices
together positively impacts
culture, performance,
organizational performance.
We talked about culture a lot.
I just want to quickly dive
into how we measured culture.
And again, Project
Aristotle or Google--
we confirm some of the
findings from that as well.
We have this model
of culture that
comes from a sociologist
called Ron Westrum.
He's looking at safety outcomes
in aviation and health care,
so safety-critical fields.
And he has this typology where
he divides organizations up as
to whether they're
pathological-- power oriented--
bureaucratic; or generative,
or mission or performance
oriented.
And you can probably, if you're
following along at home here,
work out where you fit
on this pretty easily.
It's kind of quite
a visceral model.
And there's six different
axes here that he looks at--
the extent to which
people cooperate
between different parts
of the organization.
How do we deal with people
who bring us bad news?
Do we train people
to bring us bad news
so that we can act on it rapidly
before something really bad
happens?
Do we ignore people
who bring us bad news?
Or do we shoot the
messenger and say
how dare you tell me this
thing that I don't want anyone
to know about?
How do we deal with
responsibilities?
Do we avoid them
because we know we're
going to get into trouble
when things go wrong?
Or do we believe that
we succeed or fail
as a team and share risks
because we trust each other?
How do we deal with bridging
between different parts
of the organization?
And then two things that are
really two different sides
of the same coin, I think--
how do we deal with failure
and the extent to which we're
able to innovate.
So failure here-- does that
lead to you blaming people?
Melody, you messed this up.
You're a terrible person.
Or we're building
complex systems.
Failure's inevitable.
Thank you for helping
us find this problem
that we can now do
something about.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: That's right.
JEZ HUMBLE: And that's important
if you're going to innovate.
Innovate, by definition,
is doing things that
have never been done before.
So there's a high
risk of failure
whenever you're innovating.
If people are
worried that they're
going to get punished
when things go wrong,
they're not going to innovate.
So--
MELODY MECKFESSEL: --yeah.
Go ahead.
JEZ HUMBLE: No, please.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: You bring
up so many important points.
I mean, humans-- we're the
ones writing the software.
We're writing the code.
We're operating the service.
We have to trust each other.
So I think DevOps has been
extremely powerful in starting
to break down those
walls and take
the practices and the tools
and the automation behind it
and really help to reinforce the
trust between the individuals
because this is software.
It's not going to be perfect.
There's going to be bugs.
There's going to be issues.
How we work together
in those situations
is such an important part of it.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah.
And our research backs
up exactly what you said,
which is that the way you impact
culture is through implementing
these practices-- these
technical practices,
these management practices.
So a couple of things
that we found this year
in terms of impacting culture.
We talked about the technical
management practices.
We also found that
retrospectives
are really important.
Retrospectives, learning
reviews, postmortems--
these kinds of activities
impact culture positively.
They also help create
a climate for learning.
A climate for learning
is when organizations
treat learning as an investment
or something that we should
make sure people have the
resources and time to be
able to do, not some
kind of afterthought.
Well, do your learning
on the weekend
so that you can work the
number of hours you're supposed
to work in your time card.
So what we find is that elite
performers are 1.5 times more
likely to consistently hold
retrospectives and learning
reviews and, also,
critically, to use
the outputs of those activities
to improve their work.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
You bring up so many important
points from the research.
I just wanted to share.
At Google, we see a lot of
these principles in action.
And I just wanted to
highlight a couple of them.
So the first part is how do you
take the personal out of it.
Look at the data.
Look at the code.
Look at the logs.
Look at the dependencies.
Look at traces.
Understand error rates.
Developers and operators
come back to the data
to guide those decisions.
How can we learn the
most that we possibly can
about what's happening in the
system to fix the problem?
Having a shared fate
and collaborating
between developers
and operators.
So we shared an example
today about error budgets
and how developers and SREs work
together around error budgets.
Getting everyone oriented
around what we're trying to do
and why we're trying to do
it is such an important part.
It affects communication
and affects
trust and how we work together.
Transparency.
So everyone sees the same thing.
We have tools in writing code,
in running build and test
in our code review that we
highlighted a little bit today
that makes all
that data visible.
So we're not
withholding information
or trying to control information
in your cultural observations
so that people can take
action to resolve the issue as
quickly as possible.
And near and dear to my heart--
blameless postmortems.
My development team
does them every week.
We sit down.
We learn.
We talk about what happened.
We understand what
measures we took.
We think about not
just technical fixes
but process fixes.
And we take away a
set of to-dos that we
hold ourselves accountable for.
And again, this is
just reinforcing
that we're going to take risks.
We're going to do things that
haven't been done before.
But we're going
to learn from it.
We're all here to learn.
We all make mistakes.
Perfection is, as I said
before, unrealistic.
And we're building that
trust between the developers
and operators by doing that.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah.
And I just want to put in a
quick plug for the Google SRE
book and the Google SRE workbook
that just came out last month,
I believe.
There's a lot of
discussion about how
you do those kinds of
activities at Google,
which is really great.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Absolutely.
JEZ HUMBLE: So open source.
Obviously, open source
is a big deal at Google.
You contribute a lot.
We found that, actually,
only 58% of responders
said they were using open-source
components, libraries,
and platforms extensively.
That was a surprise for me.
I expected it to be more,
and I wonder the extent
to which people
aren't considering
all the layers in the stack.
I mean, it's kind of
inconceivable to me
that anyone would not be
using open source somewhere
whether it's in terms
of the operating system,
the libraries they
are consuming,
and the other pieces of the
ecosystem infrastructure
and so forth.
But this is what the data says.
50% agreed that their
team planned to expand
use of open-source software.
And we find that it's correlated
with high performance.
Elite performers
are 1.75 times more
likely to make extensive use
of open-source components.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: So at
Google Cloud Platform,
we're very committed to
investing in open source.
Google has one of the
highest contribution
rates to open source.
We believe in the power and
influence of open source.
And you can see
some examples here
of recent open-source
contributions.
Skaffold saw some
issues that existed
in the local build and test
and deploy workflow, wanted
to help influence and
create solutions there.
Kubernetes-- we know that
the adoption of containerized
workflows is
significantly increasing--
significant community there
in terms of contributions.
Istio and many others.
When I talk to customers and
developers and operators,
there's such power in being
able to contribute and influence
how the open-source
product is evolving.
And the community
and power around that
is so significant for
enterprise customers
not wanting to be locked in.
We've noticed this change in
the last 5 to 10 years around
and the acceptance
of open source.
And it's really
exciting to see that.
JEZ HUMBLE: Google
Cloud Platform--
you have a commitment to
open source as well, right?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yes, we do.
We are committed to
being the open cloud.
And that doesn't just
mean open source.
It means open APIs and an
open platform for developers
and partners and customers to
be able to collaborate together.
So just to wrap up,
we've shared a lot
about DORA's latest
research report
on high-performing teams.
There's an opportunity
for us as software teams
to use throughput and
stability and availability
to measure our performance.
And we've seen the impact
of that in the research
that Jez shared today.
DevOps.
It matters whether it's
commercial or noncommercial.
So we're seeing with the
advent of open source--
we're seeing with enterprise
goals that are being set--
DevOps practices are
starting to be employed more
so than I think they ever have.
Gave you an example
of error budgets
and tried to highlight how
that common metric can help
reinforce availability
and a shared
understanding of
availability and how
to have both feature velocity
and stability and availability.
And then with the right
set of technical management
and cultural practices--
can help DevOps,
help create trust
among the humans that are
developing the software
and increase velocity
and business outcomes
for those teams.
So-- go ahead.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah.
I was just going to say--
I mean, you only scratched
the surface of the report.
If you want to go
download it, you can go
to bit.ly/2018-devops-report.
I think we'll put the URL
with the webcast as well.
But I mean, there's a
lot of material in there.
We've just kind of highlighted
some of the key points today.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: There is.
I have to go back and
reread it another time.
So thank you so much,
Jez, for being here.
Thank you so much for the
research that you provided
and for sharing this all
with the DevOps community.
JEZ HUMBLE: Thanks so
much for having me.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Thank you.
So stay tuned for the live Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute.
Thanks for coming back.
We're here now to answer
some live questions
from the audience.
I'm Melody, and this is Jez.
So let's-- yeah.
Let's just get into it.
JEZ HUMBLE: OK.
So one question.
Any nuggets of advice
to give to someone
carrying out an Agile/DevOps
transformation at a huge bank?
So I hear this a lot.
We're regulated-- it's
financial services,
working in government or
something-- and it's hard.
So I want to acknowledge,
yes, it is hard.
However, we do find
in the research that's
in the report this
year-- there is
no difference, no statistically
significant difference,
between verticals in terms of
your ability to do this stuff.
We find regulated organizations,
large organizations
in the high-performing and
the elite-performing group.
So you can do this.
We've seen continuously
redone with mainframes.
So it's hard.
I think the advice is probably
don't do the whole organization
at once.
Find some part of
the organization
that you can practice on,
that you can start learning,
and then take the
things that work
and move them up through
the organization--
except that there's a bunch
of things that won't work.
And that's OK because you're
learning as you go along.
So my advice is go
for it, but accept
that it's going to
be hard, and it's
going to take a bunch of time.
Don't let that stop
you from starting.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Yeah, absolutely.
When I talk to financial
institutions or institutions
in health care, this
question keeps coming up.
And I think my advice
would be similar to Jez.
Start with a small piece and
really gain some momentum
with that, because we know--
if you look out to open
source, look at some
of the research we've done--
developers look to
other developers
for help and guidance.
And when you have the success
on maybe a particular area
of your pipeline, if you start
with CI/CD, it can go viral.
And other developers
will learn about it.
They'll look to
it as an example.
And then they will
help make it better.
So start small, get
some momentum going.
And then you can
really build from that
because the culture
takes time to change.
We've seen that.
It takes reinforcement
of practices--
takes development of
tools-- which takes time,
and that shift between how
the humans work together
within whatever company it
is that you're working at.
JEZ HUMBLE: And I think
huge organizations
are very heterogeneous.
You will typically find
in a big organization
that all the answers are there.
They're just scattered
around in all different parts
of the organization.
So find the people who
are doing the good stuff,
and find ways to spread that.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Right.
Yeah.
I have also advised internal
hackathons and developer
community events within
financial institutions, where
you bring the
developers together
to talk about the ideas
that they have and some
of the changes that
they want to make.
JEZ HUMBLE: Internal
DevOps days conferences.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Exactly.
So can you talk a bit more
about misguided performers?
That was something that
the report mentioned.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yes.
And someone asked about
outsourcing as well.
And these kinds of
things are related.
So when we did the
cluster analysis,
we found this group
that is kind of
similar to the low performers.
They're releasing
very infrequently,
but their time to
restore is really long.
It's like multiple
months to restore.
And we kind of thought
there must be something
weird going on with,
like, is the data right.
We checked the data.
That's what it told us.
And if you look
in real life, you
can see things like
this happening.
So, I mean, healthcare.gov
was a good example, where it--
I mean, they got service
somewhat restored
quite in the space of days.
But it took them
months to actually fix
all the systemic problems
in the infrastructure
and fully restore service to
the level that was expected
and required of that service.
Security vulnerabilities.
If someone hacks
into your system,
it could easily take you months
to pull all that out and fix
all those problems,
fix any data problems.
So when you think
about it, that's real.
And we see it
reflected in the data.
The message is don't
assume that going slowly
is going to save you because
if you go very slowly
and release very infrequently
and think that you're
going to prevent all
the problems by doing
all this very careful
prevention work--
that's going to hit you when
something actually goes wrong
because it's going to
really impact your ability
to fix that rapidly.
So that's what the data says.
We also found a
strong correlation
between misguided performers
and functional outsourcing.
So people who are outsourcing
either development or testing
or ops--
these individual functions--
we find that elite performers
almost never do that.
Low performers do
it much more often.
And actually, our
misguided performers
were the highest users of that
kind of functional outsourcing.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
I think there's two things
that that makes me think of--
the small batches-- so how can
you control the amount waiting
too long between releases--
and having a fast iteration
cycle that happens.
We found that to
be true at Google.
And if we go back to this cycle
of continuous improvement,
where we're trying to add
in automation and insight,
I could see how that outsourcing
would be a challenge.
Are people looking
at the same data?
Are they having access to make
good decisions and exchange
information between each other?
JEZ HUMBLE: Can they
even talk to each other
and change the way they work
and collaborate effectively?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Right.
Right.
Interesting one we would
probably both talk about--
any ways in which one can drive
cultural change for DevOps?
Well, we've mentioned
some of them.
I think one of my
principles to come back
to within teams, or where
you run into obstacles,
is where does the trust
start to break down.
And I think having
a strong culture
that includes some
of the principles
that we shared with today--
they really have to be lived.
And you can come
back to at Google,
we can use postmortems
to look at where
did things start to break
down between the humans.
Were we not-- was our piece
of data that was missing--
did someone not have
access to that information?
Did we not have a
common understanding
around uptime, what uptime was?
And how was the team
not kind of coming
to the outage or the issue
that was coming up with all
of that information in mind?
So we all are responsible
for upholding culture.
And when we see it
start to break down,
we all have to raise our
hand and say what can we
do better next time.
How can we help each other and
help build the trust back up?
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah.
And you have disaster recovery
testing exercises at Google.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
DIRT testing.
[LAUGHS] Yes.
Where we deliberately
try and force things
to go down to see
where we might have
gaps in our response
and our practices.
Thanks for bringing that up.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah.
And I saw Kripa Krishnan
talk about that in the past,
and that was really amazing.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
Great practices within SRE.
JEZ HUMBLE: OK.
I think we're kind of out
of time here, pretty much.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
Went by fast.
JEZ HUMBLE: Yeah.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: I know
there are more questions.
We will make sure they get
responded to on the platform.
I wanted to say thank you to
everyone for coming today.
Thank you so much to Jez
and the team at DORA.
Stay tuned for
the next session--
Advanced Serverless Data
Processing in Cloud Dataflow.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]